[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
saluer
il est attendu un même film a dit il va
venir faire ses blagues luigina validé
dhabhawi la pensée blague bonsoir céline
thomas mich j'ai vu j'ai vu il a tout vu
sur vous exactement la même
on va commencer par votre première télé
sur france 3 nord pas de calais c'était
votre première fois en tant
qu'animatrice bon sens aussi que c'était
la première fois pour votre styliste et
pour votre coiffeuse du à oui j'adore
mes moyens me mission des créateurs de
quoi d'abord les couples bien j'allais
aller franchement elle est la nôtre
j'avais un plumeau sur la tête alors
ménard et bien c'est pas mal tout cas
mal bien sûr alors on pas ça c'est mon
choix c'est simple tout le monde est fan
de ces mouchoirs cette saison plus de
mille émissions et combien de
journalistes déjà à 35 20 disent qu'ils
bossent ouais je peux vous dire que
carré cé carré à 35 journalistes quand
même bah c'est sûr que là niveau
interview c'est carré champion du monde
donc de moustache elle doit être content
que madame c'est monsieur assez déçu
alors à quoi tu es fou il ya donc le
frêle de thierry bonjour écossais
christophe incessamment si frédéric
collet - tant pour l an passé l on
attend d arriver là
combien de journalistes déjà
d'apprentissage en alu bost oui je peux
vous dire que j'ai donc si je choisis de
johnny par exemple à coucou il est bien
ouais et des biens et laurent voulzy
belle île en mer
[Musique]
me dites pas que vous avez droit à lyon
quand même c'est vos cheveux c'est mes
cheveux à rien dernier petit qui fait
moi qui fais c'est le sosie de ta vie tu
est un fait social en allemand c'est
david gray temps je suis choisi allemand
et rien à voir j'adore sa magnifique
très fort aujourd'hui evelyne vous
animez snapped lantiéri 25
vous revenez sur des affaires
criminelles qui implique des femmes
meurtrière sochaux un soir donné une
famille est attaquée chez elle on tire
sur la femme et on tue le mari et la
fille de 9 ans assez un autre délire ya
un peu là evelyne d'avant et live in
d'après parce que moi je me souviens
bévinda vent propose d'accueillir
maintenant spiderman batman dans batman
le joker alors que la yvelines d'après
un jeune homme a été abattu de deux
balles et son corps est gravement brûlé
avec la devine d'avant c'était plutôt il
est de mettre dans mon urine toute la
journée sur moi de pas mal à laisser
sécher mes narines
à seulement 23 ans est abattu près de
son véhicule est le plus longtemps que
vous ayez passé de temps sans vous
l'avez sait combien de temps la route
est presqu'un mois je pense qu'ici ce
nom
c'est ma ville c'est le choix que c'est
tous les samedis et qui avait tu
t'éclates toujours autant oui parce que
j'aime les gens qui sont là parce que ce
sont des témoignages et c'est bien en
même temps que tu effet ce jeu sont ces
manchots avec les familles parce qu'on
voit qu'effectivement il ya des vrais
gens qui ont des vrais phobies et voilà
ça me ça me fait rire et je suis désolé
vraiment 35 journalistes que je salue
qui bossent dur et voilà mais vous
n'étiez pas moins cher stages ainsi les
stagiaires mais évelyne cher payé et
vite vous avez vous avez remarqué vous
n'avez pas été remplacés mineurs pour
moi y'a personne qui aussi stark vous
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas eu une
animatrice qui est aussi star que vous
ne l'étiez avons réglé franchement j'ai
des copines c'est pour moi évident
la plus grande star française féminine
qu'on ait eu une telle idée
[Applaudissements]
et bein c'est je sais pas alors je pense
pas dire et une colonne à l'été marianne
d'ailleurs mais c'était aujourd'hui est
aussi star que vous arrive à six
personnes s'est isolé mais rien dit non
mais aussi aux iap iap a aujourd'hui
acquis que sophie davant
sajjad or sophie mais c'est pas il
venait à la pagode de vitry ion 2 2
c'était une ville c'était la namuroise
loin devant celles du passé c'est là
c'est bon non mais alors rien mais c'est
vrai oui j'achète mes lunettes en marre
là bas vous êtes encadré il inclut la
non mais c'est vrai que j'ai mis une
femme à l'antenne en télévision
française pour moi qui étais hostile
star que vous il ya le capital sympathie
à dire que tout le monde vous alliez ait
très peu de gens moi j'ai toujours
trouvé les gens qui disent du mal des
gens c'est mon truc
personne ne dit du mal de vous voir vous
faites lui la ligne mais vous fait
l'unanimité en poche vous j'ai trouvé
tout de suite
[Rires]
sortie de route à léo d'autres choses
vous êtes aussi sur notre stop people
pour désigner review de stars d'ailleurs
vous avez reçu la star que toutes les
télés s'arrache mais messi donald
montiège dévoilé et surtout manger des
petits fours gratuit dans la loge
bonjour et bim à regarder moi comme les
sérieux montbernage va quand même pas
nous faire le coup le c'est difficile
d'être chroniqueur c'est difficile
d'être les cows a toujours trouvé une
punchline
t'es où chez sa grand-mère vraiment la
bonne humeur et la bienveillance surtout
de avec lequel c'est le moins bien passé
parmi toutes ces personnes avec toi
connard vous n'avez pas votre place
oui ça y est une info ça mais c'est sa
tombe
les petits camarades sont vraiment
sympathiques et moi ça fait 35 ans que
j'allais rapporter quoi en train de 5,2
millions qui servent à rien
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
des boules maintenant bernard montiel
c'est pas seulement un carré vip en
aller retour en jet ou une carte premium
à point soleil c'est avant tout un homme
blessé avec un coeur qui saigne
vous n'auriez pas aimé alors l'amour
c'est quelque chose de si j'aime et j'ai
eu la chance d'aimer et d'être aimé
j'ai peur de souffrir pour moi c'est
très violents et je souffre trop métro
jusqu'à la mort je veux plus ma tâche
est donc toutes mes relations sont
superficielles c'est juste du q
[Applaudissements]
connaissez-vous qui les a dérangés par
sadie salle du bar pire c'est vrai
franchement c'est l'art il va nous faire
dire des choses
ah ouais on n'a pas envie de dire elle
est très fort et vie on a envie de tout
lui dire tout et parce qu'elle est
agréable on est en confiance et fine par
une fois de plus je vois votre côté
romantique
non messieurs en plus je n'ai pas menti
sur leur que j'ai dit était vrai je sais
qu'il a ressentie comme telle phobie des
troncs trop bas et me sortit rejeté sa
requête
[Applaudissements]
c'était surtout pour terminer mais
carrément faire c'est mon choix spéciale
cyril hanouna battant c'était un honneur
pour moi exactement pour l'occasion vous
étiez émises sur votre 31
puisque vous avez sorti vos plus belles
palme on sent que vous connaissez bien
tous les deux et quand j'ai dit que vous
connaissez bien
vous connaissez bien
une émission sur mesure par céline avec
chantal qui est cachée de bigorneaux
rien ne va plus à sainte-hermine déguisé
pieds nus et encore merci à chantal
qu'ils aient droit à quoi adacore et
c'est mon rêve c'est un peu la famille
parce que même les chroniqueurs sont
passées vous faire un coucou ou prendre
un bain comment ça ouais carrément
étaler leur nom de conquête au rami
s'est faite beaucoup on va se livrer
avec moi j'aime bien d'y trouver le
bonheur
merci en tout cas on est toujours bien
reçus dont c'est mon choix du coup c'est
normal que quand vous venez dans tpm
paix vous soyez aussi à l'aise non ça
n'est pas
il est remplacé par été exceptionnel
merci luigi
[Applaudissements]